في العراق افاد مراسل الجزيره بوقوع قصف
استهدف مقرا للحشد الشعبي شرقيه بغداد من
جهتها اعلنت حركه النجباء العراقيه مقتل
معاون قائد عمليات حزام بغداد في الحشد
الشعبي طالب السعيدي وقالت ان القصف
استهدف سياره القيادي طالب السعيدي داخل
مقر للحشد الشعبي شرقيه
بغداد من محيط مقر الحشد الشعبي المستهدف
في بغداد معنا مدير مكتب الجزيره سامر
يوسف
سامر هل اتضحت ملابسات هذا الحادث ما
الجهه التي تقف وراءه و حجم
الضحايا بدايه مصادر في الحجد الشعبي
للجزيره قالت بانها تتوقع بان القصف نفذ
بطائره مسيره امريكيه نحن نتواجد الان في
محيط المقر مقر الحجد الشعبي للدعم
اللوجستي كما اكدت اكدت
هذه المصادر
للجزيره طائره مسيره نفذت
هجوما بالصواريخ على مركبه
تقل معاون مسؤول حزام بغداد في الحشد
الشعبي وهو ايضا قيادي في حركه النجباء
هذا هو المقر او السياج الخارجي
للمقر نبعد عن البوابه الرئيسيه نحو 200
الى 300 متر هذا الشارع قطع
بالكامل الاستهداف تم داخل هذا المقر بين
البوابه الرئيسيه عندما دخلت
مركبه المسؤول في الحجد الشعبي وهي تتوجه
الى
مكتبه استهدفت السياره في داخل المقر بحسب
حركه النجباء والذي ينتمي اليها السعيدي
معاون مسؤول حزام بغداد في الحشد الشعبي
فان فان الاستهداف تم بواسطه طائره مسيره
قصفت هذه المركبه وقتل السعيدي ومرافقه
فقط حتى هذه اللحظه عدد الجرحى لم يعلن
عنه حتى الان بعض المصادر من الحشد
الشعبي تقول بان لا جرحى هجوم استهدف
مركبه مركبه السعيدي وبالتالي قتل هو
ومرافقه المكان هنا في محيط ايضا وزاره
الداخليه العراقيه خلف هذا المقر الذي
تشاهدونه امام
امامكم خلف هذا المقر مقر وزاره الداخليه
بالفعل المكان يقع في شرق العاصمه
العراقيه بغداد في منطقه شارع فلسطين
المؤديه
الى زيونه الى منطقه زيونه هذا هو مقر
كبير جدا للحشد الشعبي بحسب المصادر قالت
بانه مقر للدعم اللوجستي لا اكثر وربما
لهذا السبب عدد القتلى اقتصر على المسؤول
المستهدف داخل مركبته ومرافقه داخل هذه
السياره هذا هو هذه احدى بوابات المقر
انتشار امني كثيف في
محيط المقر يبدو بان الشارع فتح من جديد
الان سامر اذا اذا صحت اتهامات الحشد
الشعبي بان هذه الغاره او هذا الهجوم نفذ
بطائره مسيره امريكيه من اين يمكن ان
تنطلق طائره امريكيه في وسط بغداد هل هناك
تجمعات قريبه للقوات
الامريكيه
بالتالي هناك معسكرات للقوات الامريكيه
وقوات التحالف الدولي في العراق ان كان في
غرب العراق او حتى في الشمال تحديدا في
اقليم كردستان العراق ولكن لم تصدر اي
توضيحات من اين انطلقت هذه الطائره هل هي
طائره مسيره بحسب روايه الحشد الشعبي ام
هي طائره اخرى هجوم من نوع اخر عند وصولنا
الى هذا المكان شهدنا تحليق مكثف للطيران
الحربي في محيط
هذا المقر كان على مسافات منخفضه في بعض
الاحيان اعيد
لاتحدث قليلا عن
هذا المقر المستهدف ليس الاول قبل ايام
ايضا
ايض يعني تبنت الولايات المتحده
وصرح وزير الدفاع الامريكي بكل صراحه
بانهم
استهدفوا مقرات للحشد الشعبي في
العراق في محافظات بابل
وايضا في واسط هذا ليس الهجوم الاول خلال
هذه الفتره كل هذه الهجمات الهجوم والهجوم
المضاد ان كان من المقاومه الاسلاميه في
العراق او الرد الامريكي
ياتي كله ارتدادا للاحداث في الغزه للحرب
على وفي قطاع غزه هذه الهجمات
التي تستهدف
ايضا مقرات للقوات الامريكيه او او قواعد
للقوات الامريكيه ستستمر بحسب المقاومه في
العراق و بالتالي نتوقع ايضا استمرار الرد
الامريكي سامر هل الاتفاقات المحدده لوجود
القوات الامريكيه في تلك المعسكرات التي
اشرت اليها طبعا هذا اذا سلمنا بحذر بصحه
روايه الحشد الشعبي بان هذه الطائرات التي
نفذت الهجوم هي امريكيه اقول هل الاتفاقات
المؤطر لوجود القوات الامريكيه في العراق
تسمح بشن هجمات على ارض العراق من قبل
القوات
الامريكيه
الحكومه العراقيه دائما ما تتحدث في
بياناتها عن هكذا حاله تقول بانها ترفض اي
رد امريكي مباشر دون التشاور مع الحكومه
العراقيه وتعتبر الامر خرقا
للسياده العراقيه الدليل على ذلك بياناتها
المتكرره واخر بيان عندما استهدفت مقرات
للحشد الشعب في بابل
وواسط بالقرب من العاصمه العراقيه بغداد
قالت بانها ترفض هذه الهجمات وبالتالي رفض
الحكومه العراقيه واستنكارها لهجمات
امريكيه في الداخل العراقي في
مدن سكنيه
ربما هو دليل على ان ربما هو دليل على ان
هذه الهجمات لا تنخرط تحت اي مسمى قانوني
متفق عليه بين بغداد وواشنطن
الاتفاقات بين الحكومتين العراقيه
والامريكيه كانت تقتصر بحسب الحكومه
العراقيه على محاربه تنظيم الدوله وخلايا
تنظيم الدوله بعد القضاء على تنظيم الدوله
في المدن العراقيه عام
2017 التواجد الامريكي الان بحسب الحكومه
العراقيه هو ل المستشارين من التح التحالف
الدولي والامريكيين الذين
يقدمون الدعم للقوات الامريكيه القوات
العراقيه عفوا والتدريب ايضا هذه
هي
البوابه
التي دخلت منها
المركبه
ل القيادي المستهدف في الحشد الشعبي
والتابع ايضا
لحركه
النجباء منعنا من التصوير امام هذه
البوابه نحاول الابتعاد
قليلا لان الاجواء
هنا ما
زالت
متوتره وتشهد انتشارا امنيا مكثفا حتى هذه
اللحظه لم يمر على الاستهداف
الا القليل اكثر من الساعه بقليل وما زالت
الاجواء هنا نعم تشهد انتشارا امنيا مكث
وكذلك تشهد انتشارا اعلاميا على ما يبدو
من كثره المراسلين والصحفيين الموجودين من
حولك شكرا جزيلا لك سامر يوسف مدير مكتب
الجزيره في بغداد سنتابع معك اولا باول
اخر التطورات وتفاصيل هذا الهجوم